you
hi everyone this Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-5 game it's been a while
since I
and did one of these videos let's try
Sicilian I actually looked back
six months so this time control used to
be considered classical on the site and
now it's rapid in order to hit classical
I think the minimum is a fifteen
time controls us 15 plus 15 but anyhow a
good opponent what to do
every game we've played has just been
like bullet thinking e6 knight c6 a6
up again with 96
Bishop to b2 okay do I insert a six are
not designed to just prevent the bishop
prevent the bishop from going to be five
yeah why not
could do many things
well my knight likes that he has this
possibility one day
and I'm not going to go to this square
it's difficult to fianchetto
let's start with this little pawn
formation so I'm playing it still as if
it's a Sicilian
he's still going to go for d4
but you know what let's just get the
night out if he's chased away maybe this
night could even take up a post on be
for one one day
I'm not really too afraid of this move
okay Knight c3 obstructing the bishop
hmmm I feel like this might be an
opportunity to play 94
and after slow slow down a little bit
then playing so much bullet in blitz
that yeah
first time playing
a control with 10 plus minutes
so I'm thinking about Knight to d4
to run away and I get the center pond
and ended up getting my deep on but the
exchange of the C pawn for a pawn would
mean itit would have a central majority
so I like that
94 is pretty
pretty tempting actually
actually what I don't like about 90
ninety four five
me some tell you what I'm just gonna be
on Sicilian fashion
to e2 is pretty conservative so I don't
want to get in d4 and now here's the
other thing 94 takes takes the night
doesn't have this movie has to go to an
awkward square probably back home
I'm gonna say why not let's jump in
difference here with the Queen on c7 is
that on e5 I could take and then take on
e5
winning upon
feels like I should have some kind of it
an attack actually exchanging the clean
night for the King night
that's why king physician can become
pretty sensitive
so I'm looking at these fishing pole
ideas Knight G for Bishop to d6 both
would threaten something pretty say it
pretty serious
this right here most serious of all
would be a Maine tonight takes Queen
takes h2
what would be the defense actually if
Knight to g4 and g3
yeah Knight g4 g3 is necessary
94g three
is this too crazy
it's actually pretty tempting
Bishop to d6 simple h3 if I try to
provide a square for my bishop I think
II five is a possibility then because
after take stakes I have to worry about
my rook and I'm time to take that pawn
back
this is pretty interesting
I'm gonna give it a go it's too crazy
we're gonna find out many to threaten g3
shut down now
white has just weakened the light
squares
my knight is hanging
so I have to do something about this and
then this now
tempted to simply take out the light
square bishop and be satisfied that I
have obtained a knife for Bishop
exchange a downside of course that I've
neglected development
some
then taking the the bishop here
not sure I'm going to take the bishop
and from here I just want a complete
development if I don't get killed within
the next couple moves I think I'm doing
all right but I might be getting killed
soon I might be getting killed soon
night here let's see if light pulls the
trigger on that
no it was definitely a
a possibility I believe will look back
with the engine but yeah okay I'm not
too concerned about this move my night
get kind of a repositioned pretty good
now this is definitely pretty serious I
probably just need to get on with
castles
d6 I still feel that this might be
pretty strong how do I complete
development with the bishop then being
unleashed here
I probably just have to get out of this
line of fire this unleashing of the
bishop and they have a lot of potential
energy let's just say Queen rook Bishop
and they could all be brought to life
with this Knight move
so just angling for d4
okay well I think first things first d6
is a good idea
yeah t6 and I'm thinking d6
very fast they have more more time than
what they began with so this is an
interesting moment I actually think I
like this move if I play to f6
these guys are released I kind of help
white justify this
well not the Queen move in as much as
the rook move I don't want to see this
file crack open so Knight f6 e5 could
have hit and these doubled pawns aren't
a liability I don't believe
so what's the plan here you know
actually both Brooke moves I'm not sure
how these files get peeled open
where would I like my light-square
bishop I'm playing with an unopposed
light-square bishop
so if I could really have his presence
felt I think I'll be doing well how do
we do this
we could go like that and III want to
get them on the long diagonal my
opponent has weakened a couple squares
here so which of these two do I go B 6
and then Bishop b7 or they go Bishop d7
and then prepare to expand and play
Bishop to c6
I'm gonna say I like this idea
here's the other thing I'm really going
for f4 now is that seems to be way to
weakening
to try to prevent that with fish of d6
then they come back over here and then
if they really want to get it in the gut
it in
hey if they're going to play a f4
should be able to do something in fact
something like c4 comes to mind
down to eight minutes
but I just kind of want to make sure I
have
for the placement of my pieces I want I
want them placed optimally
I still need a flight square once things
slow down a little bit once I've kind of
maximized my pieces I'll lean towards h6
a light square
maybe this is an idea one day
so this idea I guess that could be a
capture and Bishop here there would be
excuse me if I do this takes now that is
serious because d4 I could take on
Poisson
so what's the idea here this is an
opportunity for me to crack the position
open a little bit
what's wrong with c4
another one's pretty scary for white is
it not
alright I'm gonna give this one a go are
they missing that they don't really have
d4
a Bishop c5
here-here-here I have enough on it
so in situations like these where you
basically cannot prevent Bishop c5 I'm
more inclined to move the King before
the Queen
King has fewer options than the Queen
most likely so go with the piece with
the fewer options first so there we go
with the King move
so I could go here straightaway like
also this is that much more appealing
squeen at the same time has a
responsibility
really keep
eyes opened here
this is sharpening position is
sharpening
Oh
to do now is just take first
I think I like Bishop c5 first
clean here probably now
Bishop c5
because she has a responsibility
watch over f4 she's in babysitter mode
now this is that much more tempting
I think I want to take now
I think
here's the thing whites ready to
undermine the d5 square looking for this
move I think I want to take once
I'm going to take once
a little bit
is
it's scary Oh actually here's the other
thing I have an f5 move now
I play have five captures
and there's no is there really a great
rush with f5 no I don't think so that's
a pretty committal move I have to be
careful
I'm some pressure at the heart on the
heart of my structure armed under six
minutes thinking about B 5 and then
shoving the night
if I play here right away then there's
a capture and d4 it's pretty annoying
can also take first take there might
even be d4
you
interesting position
f-five
I don't really don't want to drop that
pond
well
I'm gonna play b5 maybe they give me the
a file
I'm also threatening to kick the knife
from the center
be very careful here take and then
Bishop c6 I mean Bishop c6 I mean should
be something just really close by like
some haymakers very close by
I was pointing out this point it's not
so easy to get the the rip to G one
unless white can establish upon a d4 I'm
kind of seeing this position where if
white cannot manage to put upon on d4
and kind of block out the bishop there's
some problems
I tried e4 right now
take stakes and insist on this move but
at the same time I could give that night
a shove here takes pawn takes or rook
takes I could kick the night
I should be pretty careful and might
want to establish a d4e for structure
just to negate the bishop because he
will not be denied the main diagonal
so kind of just prep for his presence
here okay now he's vulnerable
I can actually give this night a kick
and go here but I I think I just like
taking
here he might even jump in some kind of
you know let's just recapture the bishop
is more exposed
my a rook knows what he wants to do
in my F Rock might actually come into
play with the the oldrover
there's that
so if I take he's just going to jump in
interesting
I also have six I have to be concerned
about
who
where in the world is that my opponents
King gonna get safe
I think I want to keep him sitting
and I'm considering King 2h8 of Olives
who here here and
readygo King to g8
I don't want to give this night this
square I'm under 4 minutes
hmm
Bishop d4
Bishop d4 it's a knight move here
tactics men taken Knight d5
Queen d6
take 95 coin d6 if here I do have a
check
oh that's so
though this point is coming under fire
fast they might even do an exchange
sacrifice
hmm
tell you what let's get on this diagonal
right now
X
hope I'm not getting made it it's so
sharp
yeah my idea with that move was to go
here
you
I do have a check
and I think I want to not take that pond
you
let's go here kind of using that pawn as
a shield at the moment
I
I hit it with you know I would take with
check but there's them of and I want a
really safeguard my queen
that's why I'm doing this
I could pick him up once the smoke
clears a little bit more my queen is
really well-placed I like how things
have panned out these last handful of
moves not so much on the clock but
definitely position
at any moment I could take and then
maybe take here
maybe I'm lining up f five and five
let's just hit it
it is
tonight really can't move
probably have to go in for this now
I could do one of these things scoop the
pond up with my rookie Mike hang right
where he's at or the the brook that is
not contributing
he is protected so I could do this
probably this is more to the point
highly entangle a CLE I have the forward
squares covered by the knight d3 I would
actually drop the night think I'm just
winning here
is my only concern
position I believe is excellent how does
the king
to anything great I I think I
well hang on here chop
shop the clink it take
tell you what we're just going to go
here
as here's the thing
even if a clean exchange I'm preparing
this as well even if even if my front
probably wants the Queens to come off
but even if they do I have something
idea pressure on the V file pressure
here my bishop being opposite the the
king
so anticipating that they say let's
exchange a rook
I guess we're going to exchange a rope
you
two minutes
or just go to the B file
you
rook takes rook rook takes rook rook
takes pawn
this check I keep thinking that there's
a check there
I have this square covered I was
thinking there's a check I have to go
here and then here so I have this square
covered the rook can't get too excited
this would be me just returning so now
isn't this close to a backbreaker
one minute 30 rook g3 Queen here I have
this check
rookies free
actually three clean here take out the
night
and then take this pawn
I want to take here with Chuck here
g3 is I'm just putting it on
what am I missing minute 10
pretty sharp game must be said
think the end is near hopefully for
white am I missing anything
Queen h5
takes night very forcing
yeah Bishop takes Bishop Queen takes
pawn sweeping into g2 these light
squares are collapsing
I don't see any good checks on the offer
of a queen exchange
then consider that move
I should have some should have some
windmill action though
take care first Bishop takes Knight
Queen takes
Bishop takes
it's check
I'm gonna make it really simple I
believe
it's going to take the night
could have also considered the pawn but
I want
rook to go here and then some kind of a
discovered check is nearby
thirty three seconds five second
increment
it's a bit of an unexpected move Queen
f4 not fun when you're down on time to
encounter the unexpected really anytime
have to exchange Queens first
checks for white have to take the
cause otherwise here and then rook here
another unexpected move Bishop takes
pawn King here
and just resigned
okay
and Gigi I don't want to look at it just
yet with the engine what was I going to
do one of these two I think they're both
winning
I was lean I I'm gonna go with my
instinct and say that this is let's say
Bishop takes King here check
and then a follow-up something just
changed there oh okay I see Bishop takes
pawn King up Rick - G - and then you
have to go into discovery
yeah and and rook f2 and then I take the
Queen next
yeah I believe this is winning as well
here here here here and even with the
Queens often picking up some stuff
in fact both of these puns so let's
let's dive into the analysis just to
it's easy even calling for a million
nine here even with the Queen's of they
both are winning
Queen takes Queen takes rook takes King
h2 I end up getting this little windmill
action taking a pawn with check giving a
check going here in just cleaning house
so yeah the bishop ended up being a
killer I'm saying early on let's go to
the beginning
I was sitting early on that when I had
the bishop this unopposed Bishop I
really wanted to put him to use and
demonstrate that his presence is felt
will definitely it worked out well
having the the light-square bishop
the unopposed LightSquared bishop i got
him to function very well and i was able
to exploit these weaknesses just have a
peek at the the graph
this is how it went so after 9c3
six it's a fan of team black but then
white has some opportunity probably
around the point of and they some 95 and
it seemed a little bit fuzzy this was
the moment
where I was behind in development but I
had acquired the bishop pair once I got
some development and it was cool
but let's let's go through it here
let's see what was maybe missed I
thought there were that many interesting
game 94 it's not a fan of it prefers d5
yeah why not go with d5 establish a
Pandu on the center okay I went for some
some fancy stuff g3i
downside with this is I'm neglecting
development I've moved both of my nights
twice I am getting a valuable Bishop but
yeah this point right here is is
something like this possible
and it's not completely crazy
sometime - point seven
certainly pressure
the Queen the rook look at these guys
what are they doing
it scared me they were
fix
centralizing I guess but really didn't
look to punish me so when I was pointing
out my bishop being unopposed I'd like
to put him to use this is something
that's long lasting
a static advantage white at the moment
has a dynamic advantage in the form of
space having a direct connection between
the rook so if white is to show that you
know this lead in development is
something that has to be shown quickly
it's time is a time-sensitive thing
unlike the bishop I'm going to always
have this guy around
he's not going anywhere
I felt comfortable right around this
point especially after this I don't know
if I was voicing it I definitely felt it
I think I think I voiced it during the
video but this seemed to be a bit too
slow
gave me time to get my development in
and everything is pointing at this
bishop from here
what's the graph saying so this is where
it's equal and then eventually it just
gets better for me I don't think I
missed too much from what the graph is
showing this is something to not be too
afraid of doubled pawns in the center
especially
can be guarding some key squares and
this is the big key square and I am not
allowing white to justify this rook move
now because of the this nice grip over
d4 so is it a fan of Bishop d7 this is
where I was pointing out b6 Bishop d7 or
Bishop d7 it's a fan of Bishop d7
with the b5 idea in mind some
multipurpose one might say
for likes
makes sense bishop pair more pawns
exchange more diagonals are open and
this is the the main one
so King G - yeah probably King H - yeah
because I am going to get here
tough call though and here's the other
suggestion King eh one tough to really
say
to Bishop c5
ah I could play f5 right now what was I
oh I captured first in okay it's okay
with capturing but I think the reasoning
and I was going with was let's just take
and then the the pawns are moving far
away from the king
I get hit with f5 right now
so on f5 suppose a capture I just get on
the diagonal straight away I was
thinking of this then he jumps right in
but I do this and if a block then I take
okay so he can't move
so I could already play this f5 move
without the bishop on c6 I only saw this
move until later yeah only after this
pawn came all the way down here captured
there that got a little bit too scary
but apparently I managed it okay
some spike or anything that's going back
in White's favor
so a chop
now I went with b5 so this is the first
moment I really should have been playing
f5 and tying in with this idea to put my
light square Bishop to work
takes takes and then f5 I don't know why
didn't
should be going with our five right now
hit with f5 and there's this possibility
as well so there's two good reasons
behind this just like the two good
reasons behind a Bishop d7 so go here
and b5 well with f5 we're breaking at
this and we have a rook up and over idea
okay so f5 was better than b5
now wants to take I just got on the main
diagonal I'm happy about that
Queenie five or Brooke after d8 it likes
the Queenie five takes and yeah I didn't
want to I just kind of wanted to hide
behind the pond so
just pressure on the bishop and I guess
it's just way downhill from here I could
already go in for the doubling but I'm
gonna just run to safeguard my queen
guess it's just lost from here five and
then rook takes b2 I could do Rick takes
b2 now likes Rick a7rii k7r it takes B -
I went through k7
it takes B 1 it takes G 7 so I guess I
followed up all right rook g3 and it's
it's gone from here I have my options I
could exchange Queens and go in for the
the sequence taking out the night
- four - four - seven - eight
takes here suggest ikat I'll give a
check and then take the bishop
I see okay multiple ways to win in this
open position with the bishop pair but
it didn't get this far after I took the
night and they recaptured they resigned
there before I could capture one way or
the other on e4 anyhow it's certainly
been a while since I posted one of these
feel free these standard games are what
they're now called rapid games feel free
as usual to leave any feedback to this
rapid game in the comment section below
and hopefully you took something away
from it that's all for now take care bye
you